all right i've got here castella don't
know
what's going on that's that's alright as
well that's like a specific type of
chapter because normally it's
uh in like a block it's like a block
like which country is castella from
look it up what is castella do you want
to explain why we'll find out
like a cake of kinds right it's like a
pastry okay it looks like a pastry it's
uh
it's really [ __ ] good oh look it's
real
is it really okay so it's made in japan
looks like a little pastry dude it's
good
it's like a cream puff okay let me let
me um
sorry that's good that is [ __ ] good
spanish spanish spanish
portugal
one thing i've noticed about the pastry
here that i love
everything is fluffy as [ __ ] yeah i love
give me another one of those
those are [ __ ] clean you just want a
costello like from the shortcake
to the bread to the uh
to the whipped cream to the [ __ ]
castella everything is so fluffy
soft and fluffy soft and fluffy i saw a
bit just [ __ ]
which is why it's so easy to eat sweets
here because they find a different way
to market different kind of sweets and
they all taste [ __ ] amazing
you can't you really can't go what's
wrong with sweets well i'm going to try
something from the family mart
collection
oh is that what italian import what is
it
it's using proper italian caramel sauce
popcorn isn't caramel just sugar it's
literally just fried chicken
but like i won't lie one thing that i've
been as i've said in the pot before with
the movie theaters
i've been very impressed with popcorn
japan they have really taken popcorn
i'm not a huge fan of popcorn but let me
try it honestly japanese popcorn if you
come here it's [ __ ] good yeah you
think popcorn is like an american staple
like it's good [ __ ]
actually that's not too sweet that is
just popcorn i don't know i
don't i don't really go to a movie
theater in japan
make sure you get popcorn get the half
and half you won't be disappointed
the thing about popcorn popcorn is me is
that i'm never the one to buy popcorn
but i'll always take it if someone's
gone like i never got
like i never got out of my way to be
like okay i am craving popcorn now i
need popcorn
i'm always the guy who's just like okay
there's popcorn i mean i'm gonna take
some
if it's there but i'm never gonna go
like i'll never order my own popcorn at
a
theater no if someone has popcorn i'm
taking it yeah exactly right
if i'm offered i'm not gonna say no so
just read what this is called
this is the most unappetizing name i've
ever heard in my life okay sugar
rusk is the english name
and it's actually in japanese
are you sure they didn't like just try
to spell out sugar rush i'm just
kind of [ __ ] i'm having a sugar
where's the fortnite chug chug
wow look at that what is it let me take
one
what is okay i i look at this mini
baguette
i look at this and i'm like this should
not taste sweet if i bite into this and
why it's literally sugar on a baguette
it's sugar on a baguette
no no that's not [ __ ] up i'm not i'm
not gonna
get the [ __ ] out of here that is like
going against like [ __ ]
everything the france fought like france
fought for
they did not have the french revolution
so this could happen yeah exactly